so like most people I wanted to see a
Thor movie that took place in his home
turf no fish-out-of-water stuff no
trying to blend in with any funny lines
just Thor being Thor but after watching
Thor the dark world I might find myself
going back on that remark I know I'm
kind of an outsider on this but I'm
sorry I did not see this as a very good
film it just kind of felt like
in-between pointless exposition on a
character that really could be a lot of
fun to explore in an environment that
could be a lot of fun to explore and
what we do finally explore it it's just
kind of dull looking really this is the
dark world dark moon is boring
really this is our bad guy who's going
to replace Loki really we have this
dumbass comic relief again okay let me
start from the beginning
some evil jerk who looks like a reject
from the new Star Trek movies is trying
to capture the Infinity stones what are
the Infinity stones Oh God I know I
explain just powerful things that's all
you need to know and it's up to Thor to
stop him from getting this stone and of
course conquering earth natalie portman
is once again roped in and sadly she
gets way too much screen time more than
actually his other warrior friends have
which is really not fair I like these
warrior friends I think we need more of
them but instead not only do we get a
ton of Natalie Portman but kat dennings
good god do i hate kat dennings
in this movie I didn't like her in the
first one but at least Thor was
on-screen we could see them sort of
interact and she said something stupid
whatever if Thor is there and he's
charming and cool here every time she's
on screen she's either alone or with her
scientist friends and she is so beyond
annoying it's like remember in Star Wars
where the comedy kind of came from the
interaction off of people like the way
Luke Skywalker worked off of han Solo
and he worked off of Chewie and should
we worked off as c-3po and stuff it was
the interaction this is the Jar Jar
Binks of the Star Wars movies all the
comedy is just put into one person and
just like bings she's not funny
help the film opens up with the
scientists running around nude yeah they
create some sort of explanation
for it but it's entirely pointless you
don't need it the comedy is beyond
desperate in this every line that is
trying to be funny unless it's set from
Loki is painful beyond painful but
that's not the only bad thing about it
remember how grand and huge the worlds
looked in the first Thor here they look
nice at least the palace but aside from
that it's just kind of typical fantasy
stuff that you'd see anywhere again look
at this dark world the movie is named
after this and it is so incredibly not
interesting there's a major character
who dies in this movie I remember
thinking to myself god I should be a lot
more invested in this and I guess I felt
bad seeing Thor's reaction to it but I
personally didn't miss the character
that much because they just didn't make
that person that interesting nobody is
that interesting in this movie the
villain what are you on the scheme seen
it a million times the only thing that's
kind of enjoyable is when Thor has to
team up with Loki again this is as great
as it sounds you like seeing these two
together you like seeing them work off
each other but why they do half way
through the movie they get rid of that
idea and they don't even really start
that until the end of the first third so
that's one third of the movie hell less
than one third if this was the prime
focus maybe it would have been a lot
more fun but nope we got any room for
Natalie Portman and kat dennings saying
all their stupid unfunny stuff that
nobody wants to see the movie gives you
no time to really settle down and feel
like you can get attached these
characters which is so weird cuz there's
a whole movie dedicated to them that did
so well at doing that everybody talks
like they just kind of want to get the
story going
nobody really relates to each other
again with the exception of Loki but
that's in the movie so little it can't
really save it I guess the only other
thing that's kind of enjoyable is that
the climax does have some creative ideas
it's this device that's kind of like a
portal gun and that you can go through a
hole and come out another area get
zapped you in all sorts of different
places and yeah they do some cool things
with it but again did I really care a
Thor stop this guy did I really care if
he succeeded as quest I didn't give a
as dumb a setup as the first film
was
at least I cared for those people at
least I wanted to see Thor get back home
I don't know this isn't the worst movie
by any means but it's the time that I
felt we could really see Thor being Thor
going out into the field or traveling
through the stars I'm going to
Otherworld just swinging that hammer
doing the cool stuff once again I could
see those operatic landscapes really
taken advantage of but instead of
feeling like a really grand big comic
book it just kind of feels like a very
dull standard comic book but like I said
I know I'm in a minority and a lot of
people really like this film I don't get
it and there's certainly nothing in it
that straight-up offensive again outside
of maybe kat dennings and we're naked
scientists running around for no reason
on my opinion I'd rather save my money
for Avengers do